FEARMONGERING.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW NEW
YORK GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE LEE
ZELDIN.
CNBC REPORTED TODAY HOCHUL'S
DONORS ARE NOW SOUNDING THE
ALARM OVER YOUR SURGE AND
BEGGING HER, BEGGING HER IN
THESE WANING HOURS TO PIVOT TO
CRIME.
BUT I GUESS THAT ADVICE WASN'T
TAKEN ALL THAT SERIOUSLY.
>> YEAH, AND THE POLLS ARE GOING
TO CLOSE IN JUST UNDER 24 HOURS
NOW.
THE TIME FOR A PIVOT TO BEING A
CRIME FIGHTER HAS OBVIOUSLY COME
AND GONE.
NOT ONLY HAS SHE MISSED OUT ON
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY
CONNECT WITH VOTERS ON AN ISSUE
THAT IS MOST IMPORTANT TO SO
MANY OF THEM, SHE'S RIDICULED
THEM.
WHEN SHE SAYS THAT SHE DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO ME THAT WE NEED TO LOCK UP
CRIMINALS, THAT'S A MESSAGE THAT
IS SENT TO ALL NEW YORKERS.
WHAT YOU DO WHEN YOU DIG A HOLE?
SHE KEPT DIGGING.
SHE WENT ON MSNBC AND SAID IT'S
A CONSPIRACY AND WE'RE DATA
DENIERS.
SO SHE KEPT DIGGING, WENT ON
CNN, ABOUT WHAT SHE DIDN'T
REALIZE THERE WAS A SIDE BY SIDE
NEXT TO HER WHILE SHE'S
CONTINUING THIS NARRATIVE
THEY'RE SHOWING ALL THE
DIFFERENT MAJOR CRIME CATEGORIES
THAT ARE GOING UP.
SO WHAT DID SHE DO?
SHE WENT ON MSNBC AGAIN BUT THE
HOST CUT HER OFF AND SAID I'M
NOT SAFE.
WHEN I GO TO THE PHARMACY
EVERYTHING'S LOCKED UP AND I'M
NOT RIDING THE SUBWAY.
NEW YORKERS OF ALL WALKS OF LIFE
FORGET ABOUT REPUBLICANS,
INDEPENDENTS AND DEMOCRATS AS
WELL HAVE DECIDED THAT, YOU
KNOW, SHE'S NOT UP FOR THE JOB,
SHE'S NOT GOING TO OFFER UP BOLD
SOLUTIONS OR HOLD ALVIN BRAGG
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HIS REFUSAL TO
THE LAW.
SHE WON'T HOLD BACK CRIMINALS ON
CASHLESS BAIL SHE WON'T UNA
POSITIVELY JET ALCOHOLIC BACK
MEN AND WOMEN IN BLUE AND GIVE
THEM THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
DO THEIR JOB.
SO AS A RESULT COME TOMORROW I
BELIEVE SHE'LL GET FIRED BY THE
VOTERS OF NEW YORK WHO WANT TO A
THEIR STREETS BACK.
>> Laura: NBC NIGHTLY NEWS
YOU'LL BE SHOCKED TO HEAR LESTER
HOTEL DELIVERED A COMPLETELY
IMPARTIAL REPORT CONGRESSMAN.
>> AN ISSUE FINDING TRACTION FOR
MANY CAMPAIGNS IS VOTER WORRIES
ABOUT CRIME.
BUT AS WE FOUND, THE STATE OF
CRIME IN AMERICA IS NOT ALWAYS
WHAT IT APPEARS TO BE.
TONIGHT FEAR IS ON THE BALLOT.
>> VOTE LIKE YOUR LIFE DEPENDS
ON IT, BECAUSE IT DOES.
>> FUELED, SOME ARGUE, NOT BY
REALITY BUT BY VIDEOS OF RAMPANT
LAWLESSNESS AND SOME UNSETTLING
HEADLINES.
>> Laura: WELL, CONGRESSMAN, THE
MEDIA CLEARLY SEE HOW POTENT AN
ISSUE CRIME IS AND THEY ARE
ESSENTIALLY, AS I SAID EARLIER,
PICKING UP THE BATON FROM HOCHUL
AND COMPANY TO SAY, LOOK, I'M
NOT SAYING THERE'S NO CRIME BUT
IT'S NOT REALLY AS BAD AS PEOPLE
LIKE YOU MAKE IT OUT TO BE.
>> I MEAN, LESTER HOLT IS
PLAYING THIS VIDEO OF ME ON MY
FRONT LAWN WITH MY WIFE AND MY
KIDS WHERE RIGHT THERE, JUST A
FEW WEEKENDS AGO, THERE WAS A
GANG DRIVE BY SHOOTING.
MY TWO 16 YEAR OLDS WERE AT HOME
AT THE KITCHEN TABLE DOING
HOMEWORK ON A QUIET SUNDAY
AFTERNOON.
THERE WAS A BULLET FOUND ABOUT
30 FEET AWAY TWO PEOPLE SHOT
LAYING ON THE GROUND ABOUT TEN
FEET AWAY.
THIS IS REAL LIFE.
IT WAS THE 1980s WHEN ELECTED
OFFICIALS WERE TRYING TO
CONVINCE THE PUBLIC THAT IT WAS
JUST A PERCEPTION THAT THERE WAS
RISING CRIME AND IT WASN'T UNTIL
THE EARLY 90s THAT NEW YORKERS
OF ALL WALKS OF LIFE,
REPUBLICAN, DEMOCRAT,
INDEPENDENT DECIDED ENOUGH.
DON'T TELL ME THIS IS JUST
PERCEPTION.
DON'T TELL ME THERE'S NOTHING TO
SEE HERE LOOK AWAY.
WE WANT PEOPLE IN GOVERNMENT TO
ACTUALLY DO WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO TAKE BACK OUR STREETS
AND SUB WAYS.
WELL FAST FORWARD TO 2022, HERE
WE ARE AGAIN AND NEW YORKERS WHO
ARE HITTING THEIR BREAKING POINT
IN THIS STHAIT, NEW YORK LEADING
IN MIGRATION ONE OF THE KEY
ASPECTS IS THE AFFORDABLE OF THE
FREEDOM AND QUALITY OF EDUCATION
BUT ALSO SAFETY.
AND THEY'VE DECIDED, YOU KNOW
WHAT, KATHY HOCHUL'S NOT UP FOR
THE JOB.
WE'RE SEEING STRONG SUPPORT
GREAT ENERGY GOOD MOMENTUM.
WE JUST HAVE TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE SHOWS UP AND VOTES
TOMORROW.
VOTE LIKE YOUR LIFE DEPENDS ON
IT BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT DOES.
>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR NEW YORK
TO MAKE A DECISION, DO YOU WANT
TO SAVE YOURSELVES OR NO